well i'm gonna guess first that i'm i'm
gonna ask him and congratulate him on
the win and then sam's gonna talk about
how badly he's playing in the tournament
because that's what we usually hear
congrats on the win and uh tell us how
things are going at least this time i
have reason to make such a claim
and it's it's been it's just been a
horrible event
for all the way through and it's funny
you'd think i just came in really tired
from having this like my seventh
tournament in a row and furthermore i
had had something like six extra blacks
in my last tournament so when i saw my
pairing that i got an extra black here
as well i literally just wanted to
scream like it was getting really
frustrating and honestly an extra black
isn't even that big a deal in such a
long event but it was just to put me in
a bad mood and i've just been
playing bad and this game in particular
i think i was completely winning on like
move 20 and i just blundered a center
pawn like just straight up knight takes
e4 i missed completely and if you
blunder a center pawn usually you're
supposed to lose the game but i managed
to squeak it out
is it the case maybe as we look at fabi
not playing
anywhere near himself
wesley and and lanier not really
competing at the top that maybe the top
players have been playing so much chess
that they're
they're tired yeah definitely i mean i'm
exhausted just we've there's been so
many tournaments one right after the
other right after the other starting
from like i mean i've spent 13 days at
home since may i mean that's that's a
lot so uh
you know i i don't like making excuses i
own my mistakes and i i play bad because
i play a bad knot because there's some
external factor that's causing it uh but
yeah i mean exhaustion certainly has uh
a part to do with it
so you got five rounds to go
what are you gonna do well hopefully
play a little better i mean this game i
think the end game actually played
really well uh
once i dropped i think i think i played
basically a pretty good game aside from
just dropping a pawn on e4 for one move
uh
was this end game technically winning
i'm actually really not sure it's
incredibly close like in this position
after rookie four i mean
basically my hope is i think that if he
lets me play g4 he's probably lost so i
was most concerned about rook f1 uh rook
h1 is probably similar but basically
here
my thought was i need to i've got the
king cut i need to get king e3 and what
i need to eventually do is get my king
off of e3 get my rook to the e3 square
play f4 and then i win and the question
is can black stop me from doing that
because if i if i get that set up he has
no counter play and my king should come
and that should win the game he cannot
cut off my king so the question is can i
pull that off
uh
yeah so for example rook g1 does not
actually threaten anything uh so
here i can i was even considering
playing d5 right now
because uh if he plays rook d1 then i
think rook d4 wins uh because he will
give me a check somewhere say rookie one
check king f4 and once i get once i've
got this with my king here i should just
win because if rookie 8 i go d6 and just
it's it's gone
uh
and then yeah d7 and just wait with the
rook and i will get the king around to
g5 so it's very close i'm not sure i was
i thought he had to try something like
this and after king e3 let's say rook g1
i mean he can also give me a check first
let's say
so check king
f2 and now say rook d1 and it's hard for
me to organize rookie three i mean i can
play king e2 rook g1 but then or king e2
rook a1 is possible as well it's very
hard for me to actually organize getting
the rook to e3 in time
uh so i i wasn't sure i was pretty sure
this was my best chance to try to set up
like this but i wasn't sure if it was
actually winning or not
and then what was his critical mistake
uh so i think going back to like let's
see at the moment like back when i took
on e4 uh when he took on e4 i just
dropped the pawn i mean first of all i
was shocked he played knight d4 i
thought this was like way back when i
thought knight d4 was like a
horrifically bad move
no not not night yeah but so here
at this point this should just be very
much equal uh after a4 i mean at this
with a4 i was trying to make a draw i
was already trying to equalize but so
for example after knight c3 check as he
played which is certainly not the only
move but it's fine take on c3 takes abs
bc5 takes
yeah so after a takes b5 rook b1 and i
thought he should have played b4 i
thought this was the easiest way because
i can't really take this pawn because
then after castle i'm not
in time to stop a rook from coming to e8
with some serious problems so after b4 i
think i have to play like rook a5
uh and then
after rook a5 he can go rook c8 and once
again i cannot take this pawn but after
like basically at some point
i'll go rook b5 or something at some
point i will get this pawn but he'll be
able to trade the bishop for the night
and then it's a dead draw there's it's
not even close because once i got the
knight vs bishop it's i'm sure it's
still a draw but like knight vs bishop
it can get very annoying once my if i
got once i got d4 king d3 i really
thought i had chances
but you're saying that this end game
even down to this point you weren't
totally sure you couldn't believe it
yeah king i fade i was very surprised by
i thought this was a very bad move
because it just lets me get the rooks to
the seventh rank and then he can't
contest it i suspect actually after king
f8 what he missed was
uh rook a7 that he can't go bishop f6
because it looks like at first instead
of rook a8 and so it looks like he can
after rook a7 it looks like he can play
bishop f6 and escape but uh wins for
white after rook bb7 bishop d4
take it rook d4
and it looks like i should have to give
a perpetual but i believe i win with
rook f7 king g8 and now rook g7 he must
go king h8 and then rook h7 king g8 rook
ag7 king f8 and then rook d7 and he does
not have c2 because rookie chad is mate
so i believe this wins i and so i think
when he played king f8 that he probably
missed this rook gd7 at the end there
and this is now lost
uh so once i got the rooks like this i
mean it's just incredibly hard for black
to play like my next move is rook c7 one
he's going to have to either lose this
pawn or create a pair of rooks and let
my king get to d3 so instead of king f8
i thought he should have played h6
uh when it's not so easy for me to stop
his bishop from coming to d2 and i still
would play this with white i'm gonna try
but i i would be shocked if if i really
have anything tangible because here i
was calculating like rookie one
and he's just barely in time after
bishop g5 rook takes e8
rookie eight
and then uh bishop rook c5 bishop d2 his
bishop's just so much more active on d2
than on b2 and my king is cut and the
point is that here if knight e3
uh which i was originally thinking this
was looking very good get the king to d3
and gone but he has f5 here which i
and i can't take it with either piece
and i can't play king e2 and here it's
i should probably think about making a
draw
now rook takes i5 he'll play rook takes
e3 actually uh is even stronger and then
i probably lose so yeah it was uh
i mean i'm sure it was defensible once
his bishop was on b2 i'm pretty sure
even the rook ending once it's one pawn
up is is still a draw but it's it's not
easy and it's
take a lot of effort
all right well great analysis there
we'll let you
bask in the glow of this victory and
hopefully be able to win some more games
yeah thank you
well done sam
one game